Trong cuộc sân ở nghị An mà thử liển trẻ ba mấy làm kiểu mẹ chăm dầu ước cưỡng
và thông sao ở biểu bẹ tật nhi sao em ai của buồn sinh viê
Không biết mẹ chồng của các bạn thì nào
Con chắc của chuyện của phân tịch thủy
Xin năm 1 nghìn trị chăm sinh mẹ chính
Quay tân kiếng, nghị An đã đến để mọi cấp nhìn khác về một cân hiện này
Thuy tương nhận, bản thân cô giống như một hạt mưa sao
Mày mạnh được dưới vào buồn và tư tốt
Mẹ chồng của thủy là bà hoàn tị thay
Xin năm 1 nghìn trị chăm dầu mẹ mốt
Mà tài có bộn năng dầu và thuy lạnh an dầu ốt
Thuy mong bà hoàn thử tâm, mẹ đẹg của cô và thiệt bị uống nào
Fải phẫu thật cấp, bộ thủy mất năng cô chính tuổi
Nhà chỉ có một cậu em trái đăng thực hiện nghĩa vô con sử
Thuy phải dưới mấy khác vào việc chăm mẹ mạnh thân cô ở lại chung nhà
Sứ thử dành đó, mẹ chồng mình tối nào cũng trẻ xây mái
Bà mấy làm kiểu lo mê xan ngủ đêm với mình
Mà sợ mình trở giả của có ai ở bên
Mẹ đẹ mình người ba con châu, tư nơi mẹ đẹ mình bị bệnh
Mẹ chồng mình kiếm luôn việc cất có nguy châu
Mà sợ mình bộ tò phải làm việc năng đi làm thay thí kể
Lúc thuy mẹ chồng con vương cũng là nước mẹ đẹo con thành tà vô tần
Được chử về nhà, Thuy sẽ bộ mẹ chồng cho việc ngoại ở cưỡng
Để được ở bên nè, thương con sâu vừa xin, chống lộ nốt
Bà tài truyền sân nhà thung ra ở gần lệm để chăm sóc con chau
Mẹ chồng mình với chăm con sâu ở cưỡng
Vâ làm con việc bệnh ăn chung nhà thung ra
Mẹ chồng và gặp, đừng có lệm lệm lệm lệm hành tự lối
Đân hành lộ thuy phơi đối
Đánh đẹp lại rất cộ chựa lệm thì thẳng con
Mình quyết mẹ sân phóng các nghiệm như mẹ không chứ